un bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour
notre foire aux questions fort en
question pour laquelle j'ai accueilli
aujourd'hui clément zanoli clément
bonjour bonjour donc clément tuer tuer
paléo anthropologue au cnrs et à
l'université de bordeaux et tu as
récemment participé à la publication
d'un article sur une nouvelle espèce
domo donc un truc qui arrive quand même
pas tous les jours à une nouvelle espèce
domo qui s'appelle homo l'us open 6 et
qui a été découvert dans les philippines
alors c'est un très grand honneur de
t'accueillir parce que on accueille
quand même un des participants de cette
découverte donc c'est très excitant pour
nous alors clément est ce que tu peux
commencer par tête si tu veux te
présenter un peu et puis présenté cette
découverte et comment tu ya contribué
oui bah moi je suis donc comme tu l'as
dit chercheur au cnrs
aujourd'hui à l'université de bordeaux
et j'ai quitté l'université de toulouse
il ya quelques mois et j'ai été impliqué
dans cette étude vraiment par hasard
parce que bon déjà il ya des dents qui
ont été trouvés et ma spécialité ce sont
ces d'étudier les dents mais aussi parce
que je connais bien florent détroit le
premier auteur de cet article
il a été mon enseignant à l'époque où
j'étais en master au muséum d'histoire
naturelle de paris
et à cette époque là en 2007 on avait
été lui est moins avec d'autres
étudiants on avait été au philippines
pour fouiller la grotte de terrebonne
qui se trouve sur l'île de palawan au
sud et à cette occasion on avait passé
trois mois aux philippines on avait
aussi été visité la fameuse grotte de
callao et à ce moment là en 2007 et
venait juste de trouver le premier os de
aux molson n 6 qui est un petit os du
pierre métatarse
mais à ce moment là on ne savait pas du
tout à quoi on avait à faire vous voyez
bien qu'il y avait une morphologie qui
est relativement similaire à celle de
l'humain moderne homo sapiens mais avec
quand même au niveau des extrémités au
niveau des épis fils de saynètes à tarse
une morphologie qui quand même un peu
différente
alors on s'est posé plusieurs questions
est ce qu'il pouvait s'agir d'un autre
os minines autres comment sapiens est ce
que c'était un individu pathologiques ou
anormal
voilà mais assez à ce moment là il était
quasi impossible de répondre à ces
questions n'avaient pas plus d'éléments
pas plus d'os et c'est seulement entre
2011 et 2015 que le reste de
l'assemblage a été trouvée l'assemblage
humain avec d'autres fois des phalanges
un certain nombre de dents aussi qu'ils
ont cette dent au total et un petit bout
de dia fils de fémur d'un jeune individu
et du coup presque douze ans après non
c'est ça oui oui c'est à peu près ça
douze ans après vous fait la couverture
de nature on a eu on a eu un peu de
chance mais c'est vrai que cette
découverte est assez fascinante les les
spécimens en eux mêmes sont quand même
plutôt bien préserver aussi ils ont ils
ont un certain nombre d'éléments à ces
diagnostics qui nous ont permis de
définir justement cette nouvelle espèce
si on regarde les eaux par exemple les
les phalanges dont une courbure assez
prononcé ils ont aussi des crêtes des
insertions musculaire qui sont très
développés donc ça ce sont des
caractéristiques que l'on retrouve
plutôt chez les australopithèques où les
premiers représentants du genre homo et
pas du tout pour une période de entre 60
et peut-être sans milan avec elle sur
lesquels sont datés ces fossiles donc
donc ça c'était assez assez étrange mais
à ce qui est encore plus étrange c'est
finalement une combinaison de ces très
archaïque m'ont presque australopithecus
like je dirais avec des caractéristiques
presque moderne modern like sur les
dents notamment la couronne des molaires
et des prémolaires est très simple avec
juste des culs speed marquer mais sans
crête accessoires sans qu speed
accessoires sont lassants tout un tas de
fioritures que l'on peut retrouver sur
les dents de homo erectus et d'autres
domine plus anciens donc c'est cette
combinaison finalement de morpho le de
particularités morphologiques à la fois
archaïque et plus similaire à celles des
humains actuels qui nous ont fait penser
à une autre qu'on avait à faire une
autre espèce inconnue ans donc il y aura
une tendance à la simplification
dentaire ch dans la lignée humaine c'est
ça que tu nous dis est en fait homo
sapiens finalement il aurait les dents
plus simple peut-être parce que ils
utilisent des outils avant de
de manger parce qu'il utilise le feu
aussi ça aurait un lien avec ça j'irai
peut-être pas jusque là parce que les
néandertaliens utilisaient aussi le feu
ils avaient des outils aux mots electus
pareil et il avait des dents bien plus
complexes non je pense que ça c'est
simplement un processus de gras
stylisation qui s'est commencé déjà chez
chez homo erectus qui s'est continué
ensuite sûrement sapiens et c'est ce
processus de gras stylisation on
retrouve des os un petit peu moins
robuste des dents un peu plus petit qui
s'est accompagnée d'une simplification
finalement de ses dents et la question
qui se pose est plutôt c'était pourquoi
on avait une telle combinaison et même
au niveau des dents d'ailleurs on
retrouve donc ses couronnes au niveau de
l'émail qui sont assez moderne mais les
racines et notamment les racines des
prémolaires sont plutôt un plutôt un
modèle archaïque
parce que par exemple elles ont trois 3
branches ses racines de prévost l'air et
ça c'est quelque chose que l'on retrouve
chez les australopithèques où les
premiers représentants du robot de
nouveau mais qu'on le retrouve plutôt
rarement chez les humains un peu plus
récents et notamment chez l'homo sapiens
sont là quasiment quasiment jamais alors
du coup tu a rapidement évoqué l'âge de
ceux de cette nouvelle espèce
on est aux alentours de combien cent
mille soixante mille ans c'est ça oui
alors les datations qui ont été fait
jusque là ce sont des adaptations à
l'uranium à nous donner un âge minimum
la première datation était autant tour
67 mille ans on sait qu'il ya
probablement on est au delà de cette
date là entre soixante-dix mille cent
mille peut-être mais on a pas d'âge
maximal donc voilà on sait qu'on est
quand même dans une zone plus ou moins
aux alentours de cette zone là en terme
de chronologie c'est un peu la limite
aujourd'hui et l'autre question qui se
pose on a aussi retrouvé des restes
beaucoup plus anciens de alors cette
fois ci pas de restes humains mais des
restes d'un rhinocéros avec des traces
de découpe sur un site de la vallée de
cagayan qui se trouve à juste quelques
kilomètres de cette de cette grotte de
callao et ses ossements donc qui
montrent des traces d'activités humaines
de découpe de boucherie et bien ils ne
sont datés aux alentours de 700 mille
ans donc là on a
sur le plateau au dessus de la grotte
finalement des eaux qui sont travaillés
par l'homme et avec de l'adresse de
boucherie à 700 mille ans et dans cette
grotte on a peut-être un peu en berne
aux mines qui avait vu qu'il ya
peut-être cent mille ans donc il ya
quand même un écart chronologique de 600
milles entre les deux et on ne connaît
rien entre c'est entre ces deux dates on
n'a aucune idée de ce qui s'est passé on
sait pas si c'était les mêmes féminine
qui étaient là et qui sont restés s'il y
en a eu d'autres qui sont arrivés avant
et est remplacé voilà on n'a aucune idée
de tout ça il ya un parallèle qui est en
affaires avec l'homme de florès parce
que l'homme de florès il est à peu près
à 50 mille ans je crois il est daté à
peu près 50 mille ans mais on a aussi
des crois qu'on a une petite mâchoire
qui a sept cent mille ans aussi alors
qu'est ce que ce serait ce serait un
genre d'évolution parallèle où est ce
qu'il serait apparentée flor et ses élus
zone n 6 alors ça c'est une très bonne
question alors moi de mon point de vue
je pense qu'il ya de fortes probabilités
qu'ils descendent d'un ancêtre commun
parce qu'ils ont quand même des
caractéristiques globales qui sont assez
similaires
donc comme je disais sur les restes post
crânien notamment les phalanges les
autres du poignet et c'est sûr florès
il ya aussi une morphologie qui
ressemble à celle des australopithèques
ou de homo habilis donc premier
représentant de jérôme os et les dents
aussi sont très petite montre une
morphologie assez simplifiée pour les
couronnes mais avec aussi des racines un
peu complexes comme celle des
australopithèques donc on a quelque
chose qui ressemble entre flores et
luçonnais 6 par contre il ya des
différences aussi et qui sont assez
importantes du moins qui sont assez
disons substantielle pour pouvoir
différencier peut-être en termes
d'espèces cessé de ces deux groupes là
parce que les prémolaires et les
molaires deux aumôniers sensys on a des
dimensions qui sont différentes en
termes de ratio c'est à dire que les
prémolaires sont très grosses par
rapport aux molaires chez ovo lausanne n
6 alors qu'on a des prémolaires qui sont
relativement beaucoup plus petit et par
rapport aux molaires chez homo
floresiensis et donc le ratio qu'on
retrouve de chez molson n 6 finalement
ils se rapprochent presque de celui
qu'on a chez les parents trope donc ils
sont des cousins éloignés
qui dès qu'ils sont aussi reliés aux
australopithèques des prémolaires qui
sont plus petites que les molaires c'est
aussi se court tous c'est ce qu'on
retrouve chez homo sapiens c'est tout à
fait donc donc flores il aurait plus une
morphologie d'homo sapiens de ce point
de vue là et lui ça lui sonne m6 serait
plus donc comme les parents troque donc
les ce que les anglais appellent les
humains casse noisette
c'est ça oui alors je dis pas qu'il
s'agisse d'un parent trope mais par
contre en termes de proportion entre
prémolaires et molaires on a un schéma
un peu plus proche de celui des parents
trope que celui de l'homo florensis ou
des humains modernes et c'est simplement
le fruit d'une évolution en milieu
insulaire je pense le fait que florès
florensis et vécu sur l'île de florès
une petite île tout comme rousseau 2006
a vécu sur l'île de laussonne tiens ça a
tendance à créer des phénomènes
d'évolution insulaires qui sont assez
bien connu en paléontologie mais qui
peuvent mener à des choses totalement
étrange les animaux les plus petits qui
deviennent très grand qui ont évolué
vers des formes de gigantisme ou à l
inverse des animaux plus grands qui
deviennent plus petit des forme de
nanisme
et c'est un peu peut-être ce qui s'est
passé avec cette forme humaine qui a
probablement si elles dérivent d'un
ancêtre du type on m'aurait lotus qui
avait une stature à peu près comme la
nôtre et aujourd'hui on voit que aux
molson m6 avait des dents très petit et
des phalanges et de dimensions aussi
assez modérée tout ça ça nous laisse
suggérer une stature qui pourrait être
similaire à ces deux homos florensis
donc peut-être un mètre vingt années 30
mais là je ne veux pas m'aventurer sur
des sur des estimations mais simplement
pour donner une idée du coup le scénario
moi je vais pas dire privilégier mais le
scénario jusqu'à preuve du contraire ce
serait que homo erectus donc sort
d'afrique à autour de 1,8 de millions
d'années je crois que maintenant ils ont
même des restes en chine de deux
millions deux millions 1,1
je crois donc aux mots avec du sort ce
hors d'afrique à peu près à ce moment là
plutôt que de former une sorte de rameau
de cul-de-sac évolutif on va dire là il
commence à se répandre un peu partout en
asie du sud est
il atteint flores il atteint le son il
atteint l'île de luçon et en gros il
fait ça il fait son sa petite évolution
locales à lui s'est pour l'instant c'est
ça que c'est ça que vous pensez qu'il
s'est passé il ya plusieurs scénarios
possibles
disons qu'il ya deux scénarios qui sont
à mon avis les plus probables
alors il faudra après trancher entre ces
deux scénarios un premier qui
impliquerait l'existence d'une lignée
humaine qu'on ne connaît pas encore qui
serait directement liée à orly homo
habilis qui seraient sortis d'afrique
aux alentours de effectivement 2
millions peut-être un peu avant mais
dans ces eaux là et qui serait arrivé en
asie depuis depuis longtemps et qui
serait resté en asie mais dont on
n'aurait pas retrouvé forcément beaucoup
de traces fossiles ou qu'on n'aurait pas
identifié et pourquoi je vois que cette
hypothèse tout simplement parce que les
restes de flores montre un grand nombre
de caractéristiques qui sont compatibles
avec celles d'homo habilis et les
chercheurs qui ont fait des dernières
études sur ces fossiles ont démontré que
finalement la morphologie surtout des
eaux post crânien et bien été très
fortement compatibles avec celles de
billie alors moi de mon côté sur les
dents je suis pas totalement d'accord je
trouve que les dabistes sont très
complexes ont une morphologie vraiment
très particulière et ça ne ressemble pas
du tout à ce qu'on obtient se nicher
flores ni chez lawson n 6 est
effectivement ses caractéristiques très
archaïque sont un peu un mystère a entre
guillemets mais si on regarde les dents
par contre on retrouve une morphologie
qui as est compatible avec ce qu'on a je
suis homo erectus donc ça ce serait la
deuxième hypothèse pour moi rectus en
asie qui serait réglé la ya à peu près
deux millions d'années effectivement et
donc ils se seraient dispersés dans
toute l'asie il aurait peuple et support
probablement par plusieurs vagues
de peuplement pas forcément en une fois
les différentes îles d'indonésie et puis
serait arrivé peut-être aux philippines
il ya peut-être sept cent mille ans et
ce serait lui à ce moment-là qu'ils
seraient responsables de ces traces de
boucherie mais est-ce qu'il devrait
rester ensuite en isolement sur c'est
sur cette île de lawson et aurait donné
sérotonine s'ils souhaitent une autre
vague de peuplement plus tardive serait
revenu et et aurait ensuite donné cette
espèce ça c'est encore une autre
question mais voilà donc ce sont les
deux hypothèses à privilégier alors il
ya une chose qui est importante
à noter quand même c'est que l'indonésie
au fil du pléistocène a pu être connecté
au continent asiatique par des ponts
terrestre en fonction des glaciations
quand il ya des plaques glaciaires là
une grosse partie de l'eau de l'océan
vient s'accumuler spa sous forme de
glace sur les continents donc le niveau
marin baisse et à ce moment là on a des
connexions qui ont pu être faites au
niveau du plateau de la sonde qui avait
un plateau assez bas c'est assez peu
profonds entre guillemets pour est donc
entre l'asie du sud-est continentale et
l'asie du sud-est à un insulaire et qui
est devenu donc une sorte d'extension de
2,7 de ce continent
par contre ce qui est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les philippines
n'ont jamais été connectée au continent
puisqu'il ya des bras demain les
profonds qui sépare l'asie du
continental des philippines et donc si
on n'a pas eu de connexion par contre
est ressassé outils que ils sont arrivés
par une d'une manière différente en tout
cas pas en marchant donc là on sans
parler de navigation ils ont pu arriver
là par voie de pension d'autres fortunes
des embarcations de fortune où il ya une
autre hypothèse qui est qui était
avancée par certains collègues lors d'un
tsunami ya souvent des gros morceaux de
terre et de végétaux qui sont emportés
dans la mer dans l'océan est donc
peut-être que
si un tel événement a pu se produire a
emmené avec lui non seulement de la
faune mais aussi des eaux minines est
arrivé ensuite jusqu aux philippines ça
pourrait être une hypothèse
peut-être qu'ils aient pas si folle que
ça puisque on pense que c'est comme ça
aussi que son que sont arrivés les
rongeurs et les primates en amérique du
sud depuis l'afrique donc une distance
beaucoup plus conséquente puisque tu
évoques la possibilité de navigation
entre guillemets ça pose un peu là
question de l'intelligence est ce que
éventuellement est-ce que c'était un ami
ni intelligent lui sonne n 6 est ce
qu'il est ce qu'il produisait des outils
ou des choses comme ça alors écoute moi
je voudrais pas te dire de bêtises parce
que j'ai pas eu accès au registre
archéologiques je ne sais pas ce qu'il
était vraiment de trouver dans ces dans
ces niveaux là dans la grotte de callao
je crois qu'il n'y a pas vraiment
beaucoup d'outils en tout cas voire pas
du tout associé à ces restes humains et
ce qui est aussi sûr c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de reste crânien a parlé dans il n'y
a pas de dos du crâne
donc on ne peut rien supposer sur son
volume endocriniens sur la morphologie
de l'endocrâne et donc sur son
intelligence ou ses capacités communiqué
du coup on aurait peut-être les justes
les possibles traces de boucherie qui
sont pas forcément qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément été fait par l'ue semaine si
ce dont tu parlais tout à l'heure tu as
fait et puis ça ne présuppose pas
forcément d'une intelligente puisque
l'on retrouve des possiblement des
traces de boucherie en afrique nous
entoure de trois millions d'années
et donc c'est à ce moment là ce serait
peut-être des australopithèques qui
aurait fait ces traces qui auraient de
découper les les eaux pour pour manger
la viande autour donc difficilement
attribuable à une forme d'intelligence
avancer ou ou si on veut à des capacités
cognitives plus développés question qui
peut paraître bête mais qu'à mon avis
beaucoup de nos auditeurs se pose
surtout parmi les
les - les moins formés on va dire à la
paléontologie
donc vous avez identifié trois individus
en tout donc toute l'équipe qui
travaillait là bas vous avez réussi à
créer une nouvelle espèce donc à trouver
suffisamment de caractère distinctif
pour faire une nouvelle espèce et je
pense que la question qui se pose
naturellement c'est comment on identifie
une nouvelle espèce et trois individus
sur la base de à partir de peu de
matériel comme ça et qu'elle est quelle
confiance on peut accorder à une
identification comme ça alors là c'est
vrai qu'on a affaire à seulement 13 très
spécimens en touche qui est pas énorme
il faut le reconnaître mais malgré tout
il ya quand même des espèces qui ont été
attribuées sur la base d'une seule dent
ou une seule mandibules par le passé ça
s'est fait alors aujourd'hui il ya des
gars certaines de ces espèces qui sont
remises en question mais malgré tout
quand on a des éléments qui montrent des
différences par rapport à tout ce que
l'on connaît des différences marquées et
bien là l'hypothèse d'une espèce peut se
peut se comprendre
alors dans ce cas ci pour paulson m6
bien ça s'est passé comme je les dis
d'abord on a découvert son premier
métatarse qui était un peu bizarre
alors malheureusement dans le registre
fossile n'y a pas énormément de
comparaison possible pour homo erectus
on ne connaît que très peu de reste mon
post crânien donc il a fallu regard
attendre d'avoir les dents notamment
pour pouvoir avoir plus d'information
est sur les dents et bien en les ans les
étudiants de en détail on s'est aperçu
que il y avait donc ce fameux ratio
entre prémolaires et molaires déjà
qu'ils étaient sortait de l'ordinaire
chez homo on le retrouve quasiment
jamais alors que c'est quelque chose
qu'on retrouve séparant rock par exemple
de manière commune donc ça encore une
fois ça ne signifie pas qu'il s'agit
d'un parent trope simplement il a une
caractéristique qui sort un peu de
l'ordinaire pour le genre homo et puis
ces fameuses combinaisons entre des
courants simplifiée et des racines
archaïque
là aussi c'est quelque chose que l'on ne
retrouve pas ni chez homo erectus ni
chez homo floresiensis en tout cas pas
de cette manière
ni chez homo sapiens est donc en
regardant à la fois chez l'humain actuel
et chez les humains fossiles qu'ils
pouvaient avoir habité dans cette zone
là en asie voire même jusqu'en afrique
on ne retrouve aucune espèce connue qui
partagent tout c'est cette combinaison
de ces caractéristiques l'a donc là la
conclusion qu'on a tiré c'est qu'on
devait avoir à faire une nouvelle espèce
et même si je suis sûr que certains
collègues ne seront pas forcément
d'accord avec cette interprétation et ça
se comprend ou après c'est défendable
je pense que l'un des arguments
supplémentaires c'est aussi de se dire
qu'on est dans une île sur une île en
milieu insulaire encore une fois le
l'évolution agit comme un laboratoire
on se retrouve avec des animaux et donc
aussi des aux mines qui évolue de
manière bien plus différente de ce qui
peut se passer sur le continent quand il
ya beaucoup plus des changes en termes
de génétique de flux génique
et puis aussi en termes de paléo
environnement où l'environnement est
contraint avec des ressources limitées
et donc ils ont ils n'ont pas vraiment
le choix que de s'adapter de changer
rapidement s'ils veulent pas disparaître
ouais c'est assez formidable cette
évolution insulaire chez l'humain et ce
qui est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant c'est
de comparer par rapport à je crois que
c'était en 2004 que l'homme de florès a
été annoncé pour la première fois si je
me rappelle bien donc en 2004 on annoncé
l'homme de florès et depuis il ya eu
débat pour savoir si c'était pas
simplement un individu pathologique un
pauvre humain moderne mais malade qui
aurait eu du coup des dimensions petit
mais pas à cause de sa maladie
donc il ya eu tout ce débat qui a duré
pendant pendant presque 15 ans et qui
dure encore ie6 jeu si je ne m'abuse
et maintenant avec la découverte de homo
l'us open 6
j'imagine que ça va enfoncer cloud peut
savoir enfoncer le clou pour dire que
l'évolution insulaire le nanisme
insulaire c'était plutôt une c'était
plutôt une règle aucune exception
est-ce que vous en veux est ce que c'est
quelque chose auquel tu as pensé
oui alors pour revenir l'histoire du
débat de flores ça a été très très
débattue en surtout entre 2004 et
pendant une dizaine d'années à peu près
et ce sont des collègues australiens qui
ont avancé l'hypothèse que ces spécimens
de flore et c'est notamment elle bien
lolo type puisse être un individu
pathologique atteint du syndrome de
donne donc une trisomie mais les
arguments et les les éléments
quantitatifs qui ont été avancées on
était quand même assez faible et eu des
réponses par plusieurs collègues
plusieurs dans plusieurs études qui ont
démontré finalement que c'était une
hypothèse qui ne tenait pas la route
donc après est-ce qu'on n'avait pas à
faire tout de même un individu non pas
homo sapiens mais d'une autre d'une
autre espèce peut être que l'espèce
justement florensis se vaut pour le coup
mais qui pourrait être aussi
pathologique parce que malgré tout dans
cette
dans cette liste de caractère qui avait
été avancé comme argument pour le
syndrome de drones de deurne
on a effectivement des choses qui
sortent un peu de l'ordinaire si on a
affaire à un individu qui n'est pas
pathologique il ya des asymétries très
forte sur la face est un certain nombre
de d'éléments comme une des rotations à
90° des prémolaires dans les dents dans
la mâchoire
donc ça ce sont des éléments qu'on
retrouve ou bien chez des hybrides ou
alors dans certains cas pathologie donc
effectivement l'idée de la pathologie
n'est pas forcément exclure par contre
je pense clairement qu'on a quand même
pas affaire à des homo sapiens mais à
une autre espèce est donc florensis peut
se justifier
et puis donc pour revenir à 7
cette différence entre entre flores et
douce en n 6 et donc à ces phénomènes de
l'insularité
je suis assez d'accord effectivement
pour dire qu' il ya eu plusieurs
expériences évolutive qui ont eu lieu
dans ces îles il y en a probablement eu
beaucoup plus et on ignore ans n'a pas
encore retrouvés et ont peut-être qu'on
ne retrouvera pas de fossiles puisque
les fossiles c'est uniquement ce qui se
préservent et malheureusement tout ne se
préserve pas mais il ya de très grandes
chances effectivement que d'autres
d'autres groupes aux minimes soit allé
sur les îles dans l'asie du toute l'asie
du sud est
il y est occupé pendant plusieurs
dizaines voire centaines de milliers
d'années et peut-être et développé des
caractéristiques qui leur soit propre et
finalement est dérivé vers de nouvelles
espèces ça c'est tout à fait possible et
même très très probable je dirais
puisque tu parle de préservation
j'imagine que c'est la question
inévitable adn ou pas adn tout à l'heure
tu nous parlais de deux ministères et ça
me fait penser justement à ces récentes
études génétiques qui ont découvert des
gènes de d'hominidés inconnu dans les
populations justement du sud est
asiatique donc ça
du coup ça me fait penser à ce que est
ce qu'on aurait une trace de l'us open 6
mais je vais le voir au déni souviens
bien je vais je vais justement de
détailler un peu tout ça alors pour
répondre à ta question très brièvement
nom pad adn
on a eu on a fait des tests sur une des
dents malheureusement ça n'a rien donné
les progrès de la paix le génétiques
sont quand même assez ces flux
foudroyant et je pense que rien n'exclut
que dans quelques années on puisse
effectivement extraire de l'adn de
spécimens surtout ceux qui sont
préservés en milieu tropical puisque on
a affaire un milieu qui dégrade assez
facilement les molécules avec la chaleur
l'humidité mais bon rien n'empêche que
peut-être un jour on aura les
compétences technologiques et le moyen
d'extraire et de séquencer l'adn qui a
été complètement fragmenté et qui
aujourd'hui est introuvable
mais sinon pour revenir au dénisoviens
donc ces fameuses aux mines ont donc on
connaîtrait principalement par l'adn on
a quelques quelques restes fossiles
c'est comme ça qu'on a on n'a plus
retrouvé l'adn mais on connaît très peu
finalement de céder ni sow bien on
connaît juste de dents permanentes et
quelques dents de lait et des fragments
d'os notamment un fragment de crâne qui
était à découvert et est annoncé il n'y
a pas très longtemps
et puis des petits bouts d'os de
phalanges et des fragments mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est que ces
dénisoviens ils ont dû vivre dans toute
la partie de l'altaï puisque c'est là on
les a retrouvés et très probablement
comme tu l'as dit on en retrouve des
traces génétiques dans les populations
actuelles d'asie et d'asie du sud est en
partie donc ils ont probablement vécu en
asie c'est dénisoviens et donc ça veut
dire que en asie en alentours de
cent mille ans à peu près 70 cents mille
ans eh bien on avait au moins quatre
espèces qui ont cohabité en plus de
l'eau sensi son avc dénisoviens on avait
au moins rectus qui restent et jusqu'à
où il ya au moins cent mille ans voire
70 mille ans en indonésie à java il ya
florensis juste à côté entre 50 et 90
mille ans et puis il ya homo sapiens qui
arrivait là aussi en asie il ya au moins
cent mille ans voire peut-être plus et
qui a commencé à également aller dans
les îles dans cette période là donc
voilà toutes ces espèces humaines
fossiles se sont peut-être rencontrer
peut-être pas mais en tout cas ils ont
cohabité pour certaines dans toute cette
zone est la question qui se pose c'est
est ce qu'il ya eu des échanges
génétiques et ce qu'elles ont pu
effectivement s'hybrider mais ça
aujourd'hui on a encore du mal à
répondre à ces questions là en tout cas
là la génétique et la paléogénétique
actuelles ne nous permettent pas d'y
répondre
on est peut-être au-delà de la zone de
confort là mais on a une idée de
pourquoi elle aurait pu disparaître tout
c'est pourquoi pourquoi aujourd'hui le
monde n'a plus que homo sapiens alors
que finalement semblerait que plusieurs
respecte plusieurs espèces qui
cohabitent ensemble ça c'était la règle
pendant toute l'évolution humaine on a
eu des australopithèques et les parents
trope homo s'est rajoutée par dessus et
pouf d'un seul coup homo sapiens est
arrivé il ya plus personne
et oui je sais pas si ces homo sapiens
arrivé il ya plus personne peut-être que
l'arrivée d'homo sapiens a poussé ses
autres espèces de l'extinction peut-être
pas là je géo qui ne suis pas le dernier
mot c'est un débat qui est aussi valable
pour les l'extinction des néandertaliens
en europe est ce que ce sont les là
est-ce que c'est l'arrivée des d'homo
sapiens qui a qui a poussé vers leur
extinction ou pas je vais pas rentrer
dans ce débat là mais mais par contre
effectivement ce qu'on constate c'est
que ces espèces fossiles que ce soit
homo erectus les dénisoviens
romao florensis promotionnelle six ont
disparu et très vraisemblablement
disparu il ya au moins cinquante mille
ans voire plus alors comme on n'a pas
retrouvé énormément de respect pour
lawson m6 on peut pas vraiment dire
pourquoi et quand est-ce qu'ils ont
disparu la même chose pour pour luz pour
comme employé sensys à java en indonésie
on a des restes jusqu'à il ya peut-être
70 mille ans voire peut-être un peu plus
récents pour homo erectus
là on a on a un peu plus de reste un peu
plus de deux spécimens les crânes
notamment qui ont été retrouvés sur les
sites de nos gants donga oui montre une
volume endocriniens assez élevé pour
homo erectus et puis une certain presque
un début de globules arrêté dix ont une
des crânes qui sont un peu plus haut
verticalement que homo erectus dit
classique qui est plus ancien donc là
est ce que la question se poserait
également est ce qu'on a à faire des
hybrides est ce que l'arrivée d'homo
sapiens a pu engendrer des hybrides ou
alors est-ce que bien là leur évolution
sur l'île de java a mené à des crânes un
peu plus grands un peu plus élevée et
finalement une sorte de convergence
d'apt hâtif vers vers ce qu'on a chez
homo sapiens mais voilà où là
aujourd'hui je peux pas dire pourquoi
toutes ces espèces ont disparu et
pourquoi homo sapiens subsistait ça
reste un grand mystère
sans spoiler est ce que est ce qu on
devrait s'attendre à du à des nouveautés
dans je ne sais pas dans les semaines
dans les mois à venir ce qui est ce
qu'il ya des choses dans les rouleaux en
ce moment non la seule chose qui est
dans les rouleaux c'est l'article sur le
contexte
donc c'est à dire tout ce qui est avec
le détail des datations la géologie
voilà tout ce qui devrait accompagner
finalement la découverte de déso cet
article est soumis il est encore en
révision il n'est pas encore accepté
donc je ne sais pas quand est-ce qu'il
sera accepté s'il le sera je pense un
moment mais voilà je ne peux pas aller
plus loin pour l'instant j'ai aucune
idée de ce qui va se passer avec cet
article pourra continuer ses études
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on a on a publié les
dans les grandes lignes la morphologie
et les caractéristiques principales qui
ont permis la diagnos de cette espèce
homo you soon n 6 mais maintenant il va
falloir aller plus en détail
essayez de voir en comparant à plus de
fossiles à plus de matériel
notamment pour mon cas pour les dents
puisque jusque là on a pu comparer la
morphologie 3d à seulement une seule
prémolaires d' homo floresiensis et
comme c'est tout de même l'espèce la
plus proche aussi bien en terme de
morphologie chronologie et
géographiquement aussi avec homo erectus
donc il va falloir essayer d'aller plus
loin dans les comparaisons avec homo
floresiensis essayer de comprendre si
effectivement on peut avoir à faire à
une espèce qui dérivent d'un ancêtre
commun ou alors une flore essensis qui
est qui seraient partis très tôt de
flores et qui serait arrivé aux
philippines
je sais pas quelques centaines de
milliers d'années voilà donc il va
falloir aller plus loin dans en termes
de compréhension de cette nouvelle
espèce
mais à part ça il ya aussi pour les eaux
d'ailleurs pour lui tous les restes
crânien et pop créé l'impôt scanner
pardon on va pouvoir faire des analyses
de l'eau sportica l'est de l'australie
cullers pour essayer de comprendre la
biomécanique et donc avoir plus
d'informations aussi sur leurs habitudes
leur vie finalement voilà de tout ça
c'est ce sont les perspectives pour
l'étude de homo
leçon n 6 et puis les fouilles vont
continuer donc on espère y aura d'autres
restes et peut-être des restes crânien
de femmes au moins dos du crâne qui nous
permettront d'avoir au moins où la face
ou une idée de l'endocrâne et du crâne
ce soit en terme de morphologie et de et
de peut-être de capacités cognitives un
certain moment d'accord merci beaucoup
clément de nous avoir accordé cette
interview
merci jeu mais bon j'espère qu'on
reverra bientôt pour plus de
de belles découvertes comme ça merci et
puis oui avec plaisir on se retrouve à
la prochaine découverte et bien merci à
tous de nous avoir écoutés et à très
bientôt sur notre chaîne
[Musique]